Speaker 1: This is not particularly
good news for Donald Trump.
Ron DeSantis has again defeated Donald Trump
in another one of these 2024 Republican
straw polls now. The straw poll is a little
different than the normal polls that we talk
about when we talk about presidential elections.
So let me explain to you what's going on.
Newsweek reporting Trump Loses to DeSantis in
2024 straw poll at Conservative Summit. Again,
Florida's Governor Ron DeSantis was favored for
a second year over former President Donald Trump
to be the Republican Party's 2024 presidential
nominee. At a conservative conference. This was
held in Colorado. It's the Western Conservative
Summit. They always do these straw polls. Now,
if we look at the results, you will see that
this is a picture of the screen at the event.
These numbers don't add up to 100. So Ron DeSantis
coming in first at 71% and Donald Trump coming
in second at just under 68%. Then you've got
Ted Cruz, Ben Carson, Sarah Huckabee, Sanders,
Tim Scott, Mike Pompeo, Donald Trump, Junior,
Nikki Haley and Mike Pence. Why don't they add up
to 100? Voters are allowed to make more than one
choice. This is what's called an approval poll.
And I think there's even a yeah, Newsweek has a
paragraph about this because voters were allowed
to make more than one choice through the approval
voting method, the percentages add up to more than
100%. This minimizes spoilers and sabotage
and gives viability and visibility to minor
candidates. So the idea here is you just check
off who would you approve of being the nominee?
And more people approve of DeSantis being the
Republican nominee than Trump, but not by much.
Now, what's very interesting to follow about this
is that Trump and his Santas are already feuding
for the most part. Every once in a while
they'll say something polite about the other.
But this all started when Ron DeSantis refused
to rule out that he'd run against Trump in 2024.
Trump has no problem, I guess, with DeSantis
saying, If Trump didn't run, I would consider
running. I would bow down at the altar of
Trump and let Trump have it. If Trump wants it.
If Trump doesn't want it, I'd consider it. But the
Santos didn't rule out running against Trump. He
didn't say, I'm planning to do it, but he didn't
rule it out. This we had reports of months ago,
which we talked about in some detail, set Trump
for a tailspin. Trump now hates the Santos,
and DeSantis has also started to distance
from Trump. DeSantis has started saying,
I shouldn't have listened to Trump so much early
on in the pandemic. I don't remember him listening
very much to Trump, to be honest. But that's what
the senators have said and Trump has been saying.
DeSantis benefited from my help early in the
pandemic, and they're no longer getting along with
each other. So we're going to follow these numbers
very closely. But maybe the most interesting thing
about all of this is that we are now seeing the
closest numbers we have ever seen in the betting
markets for who will be the Republican nominee.
If you go to predict it, dawg, what these numbers
show us are how much money do you need to bet to
win a dollar? So basically the more you need to
bet to win a dollar, the more likely that outcome
is because that's how odds work. These numbers are
as close as they've ever been. Donald Trump is
now at $0.38 and Ron DeSantis is now at $0.34.
This is the closest they've ever been. At one
point, they were much further apart. And in fact,
if you look at the Ron DeSantis numbers here, if
I can pull them up, I guess I have to be logged in
in order to do that. Uh oh. Okay. Here we go. So
if you look here at Trump and DeSantis, they oh,
this is not even close enough. Here we go. So
as you can see, the numbers have gotten closer
and closer. Early in March, you had Trump 39 and
DeSantis 27 separated by 12. And as you can see,
mostly as a result of DeSantis consolidating
support from other candidates, without Trump
really declining much, they are now almost tied.
And remember, this isn't who would you vote for?
This is who do you believe will be the nominee?
We have never seen it this close in terms of
us on the left. What do we care about? We care
about whatever scenario gets us to something other
than Trump or Pence as president in 2024. I don't
really care who the nominee is as long as they end
up losing. Now, of course, at a certain point
we would ask the question, which nominee is
more likely to lose? Is it Trump or is it Pence?
I don't know the answer yet. We don't have great
polling on that yet, although I expect it to
start soon and definitely after the midterms
if Trump would be easier to beat. I'd rather it
be Trump. If DeSantis would be easier to beat,
I'd rather it be DeSantis. The X-Factor is
DeSantis is less incompetent than Trump,
and that probably makes him more dangerous because
he might be better able to get things done.
This is a conversation we will have time for. But
those are the latest numbers. DeSantis looking
increasingly strong against Trump. I want to hear
from you. Leave a comment. Send an email. Send a
tweet. Who would you rather the Democratic nominee
run against? Would you rather run against Trump,
or would you rather run against the
Santos? Let me know. We'll do a follow up.